[Musique]
c'est la préparation normale à une
rentrée qui sera loin de l'être
le fils des miliband al piché commence
la première année ils doivent fréquenter
le service de garde après l'école pour
l'instant sais pas comment ça va
fonctionner mais oui c'est aussi
l'inconnue pour nacira boukellal et il
nous a envoyé un courriel pour quoi ils
vont nous envoyer par la suite un autre
courriel
comment que ça va se passer comme ça
vous tente mais on n'a pas le choix
quand tu travailles et ben ali sont pas
très claires donc on est content parce
que c'est le plan de québec et détaillé
pour le retour en classe sécuritaire il
l'est beaucoup moins pour le retour des
services de garde en milieu scolaire ce
type au grand chose selon les courtes
directive les services de garde devront
respecter le plus possible concept de
bulles classe une façon de limiter le
nombre de contacts des élèves mais
difficile voire impossible à respecter
une fois l'école terminée ou encore
pendant les journées pédagogiques tendue
vers 85 1 que des parents commencent à
venir chercher les enfants
les bulls vont être de plus en plus
difficiles à respecter les enfants vont
se retrouver des fouets tout seul de sa
vue dans un coin donc on devra mixer
peut-être certains groupes ensemble donc
ils vont être en bonne place le jour et
celle de l'opéra éclaté pour les groupes
en service de garde
un casse-tête annoncées même si les
consignes ou doivent être adaptées à la
réalité de chacun les milieux selon le
ministère le manque de précision fait
craignent les éclosions pour les
éducateurs c'est inquiétant parce qu'on
veut pas on veut pas servir des espaces
de propagation s'il ya des failles en
crise d'accor que le pointer du doigt
les services de garde de piston on n'a
pas réussi à percer parfaitement comme
ce fut en ajoutons le manque de
personnel qui n'est pas seulement
criante pour les enseignants mais aussi
pour les éducateurs en service de garde
difficile donc de se préparer
complètement à cette rentrée qui
s'annonce est prévisible et si jacques
andré charbonneau raid au canada mon
frère